je commencerai ce monde sans la peur de
femmes je parle pas de la peur soudaine
face à un danger qui nous alerte pour
qu'on puisse agir
je parle de cette peur flou et constante
qui nous freine qui nous rappelle teese
qui nous emprisonnent cette peur et
s'inscrit dans notre corps au lieu de
prendre notre place nous serons petit et
instable est faible ça va jusqu'au point
où nous considérons notre kop a comme
une partie entière de notre être mais
comme un ami ennemi qu'il faut
discipliner et combattre à tout prix
cette part s'inscrit aussi dans nos
relations par peur d'être sûr de ne pas
être aimé nous acceptons d'être en
couple en amitié en famille là où nous
sommes allés mais nous protestons pas
contre les injustices que ça soit au
public qu'en privé par peur de
représailles et nous reculons non limite
pour accommoder les besoins des autres
nos propres besoins restent insatisfaits
7 passes inscrit même dans notre langage
nous marchons nos mots au lieu de dire
oui quand c'est lui et non quand c'est
non et avec je crois peut-être j'ai
comme l'impression que on affaiblit
tellement notre message que le jeu en
finisse par ne plus nous écouter
évidemment cette peur c'est un fameux
obstacles pour prendre une partie égale
une place égale dans la société
elle nous empêche de devenir les
meilleures personnes qu'on peut être de
réaliser tout notre potentiel et moi je
me bats contre cette peur et je suis
arrivée elle c'est plutôt par ma propre
peur quand j'avais 18 ans j'ai déménagé
pour mes études de ma ville natale en
autriche à vienne grandes villes que je
connaissais pas où je connaissais
personne
et comme toute fille de 18 ans
j'avais envie de sortir de faire la fête
m'amuser de rencontrer des gens de
profiter de la vie mais il ya cette peur
elle aurait presque réussi à m'enfermer
et alors j'ai suivi un stage
d'autodéfense féministe et un monde sait
tout mais à moi j'ai découvert que je
pouvais faire confiance en mes
intuitions que j'étais capable que
j'avais beaucoup plus de force que je ne
pensais que je pouvais crier poser des
limites très clair ça m'a donné un
sentiment d'indépendance des libertés
c'était une révolution
j'avais envie de partager cette
révolution anti peur avec d'autres
femmes
et quand dans mon groupe d'entraînement
douter défense on m'a proposé de 2000
fois matrice j'ai tout de suite dit oui
et bien en pendant cinq ans à côté de
mes études j'ai donné des stages
d'autodéfense pour femme et pour filles
et puis la vie l'amour m'a emmené en
belgique
et quand je suis arrivée à bruxelles
capitale européenne
j'étais tout étonné qu'ils n'avaient pas
la même chose en autodéfense unique que
viennent à vienne à l'époque il y avait
déjà à trois différentes méthodes qui
était diffusée dans tous les quartiers
via des structures qui s'appelle les
hôtes l'école du peuple et c'est des
bâtiments dans lesquels on organise
plein différents cours pour n'importe
qui à prix très démocratiques et donc on
peut apprendre les langues l'histoire de
l'art et pressa voiture fait la cuisine
et se défendre et ici à bruxelles y
avait rien de tout ça il n'y avait pas
d'association féministes donc lui plus
que propos c'est de l'autodéfense et je
comprenais pas pourquoi
puis j'ai organisé mes premiers stages
d'autodéfense à mon propre nom et je me
suis vite vite rendu compte pourquoi
parce que en fait il y avait une idée un
peu bizarre de ce que c'est l
autodéfense pour femmes comme je
travaille on nous mixité avec des
groupes uniquement des femmes il
des gens qui pensaient que forcément ça
devait être un truc anti mec qu'on a le
remonter les femmes contre les hommes et
mener à la guerre des sexes ou encore
toute façon les hommes avaient toujours
un attrait plus fort que les femmes et
donc ça savait rien ou pire en apprenant
à se défendre les femmes allaient
prendre une faux sentiment de sécurité
prendre des risques est encore plus
devenir victimes de violences ou encore
apprendre aux femmes à se défendre
c'était culpabiliser les femmes qui
avaient déjà vécu de la violence et
s'était déresponsabilisé les hommes
d'arrêter d'être violent j'en revenais
pas je dis scotché à vienne a passé
comme une lettre à la poste que madame
tout le monde parce qu'en stage d
autodéfense et à bruxelles
c'était une prise de position politique
en tant que ses ministres à du cac et ce
dôme
donc je me suis rendu compte que justo
notre maison des stages ça n'est pas
être assez pour se monter cette
résistance là et que tout seul
aussi je n'avais pas la force pour y
arriver et donc avec ma compagne on a
crié l'association garance notre but
était double on voulait d'un côté créé
une structure qui puisse défendre
l'autodéfense féministe changer cette
image caricaturale et de l'autre côté on
voulait former plus de formatrice où que
je sois pas la seule à porter le projet
et on a réussi seul de coûts mais comme
souvent dans la vie ça a quand même mis
un peu plus de temps que ce qu'on y
pensait c'est quoi en fait c'est trop
tôt défense féministes dont je parle
depuis tout à l'heure c'est une approche
globale à la prévention primaire des
violences basées sur le genre traduction
prévention primaire ça veut dire tout ce
qu'on peut faire avant qu'un problème
arrive pour qu'il n'arrive pas donc on
veut pas juste apprendre comment se
défendre contre des violences on veut
qu'il y ait moins de violence
et les violences basées sur le genre et
les violences qui nous touche
différemment spécifiquement en fonction
de notre position sociale en tant que
femme
l'autodéfense féministe a été développé
déjà il ya plus de cent ans quand les
suffragettes anglaises ont appris à le
ju jitsu pour se défendre contre les
attaques de la police est avec les deux
guerres mondiales cette pratique est
tombé dans l'oubli et quand il y avait
le deuxième la deuxième vague féministe
enfin les années 60
les militants devaient tout réinventer
de cerveau il savait même plus qui en
avait avant elle qui avait fait la même
chose
et elles sont parties de trois constats
le premier constat était que en tant que
femmes nous sommes confrontés à des
agressions sexuelles de la violence
conjugale et harcèlement sexiste dans
tous les aspects de notre vie que ce
soit à la maison au travail dans la rue
à l'école partout
deuxième constat on voudrait bien faire
quelque chose contre ça mais en fait on
est mal préparé notre éducation elle
nous pousse à être prévenante polissage
et c'est justement les choses qui
marchent pas post vendre troisième
constat bas déjà à l'époque il y avait
des coudes à martiaux mais qui ne tenait
pas du tout compte de ses spécificités
et donc ce qu'on ne pouvait y apprendre
c'était peu ou pas du tout utile pour la
majorité des femmes dans la majorité des
situations et donc elles ont pris des
techniques simplifiées d'un martiaux et
ils ont autour de ça crée une pédagogie
qui est basée sur la notion des limites
personnelles alors une limite personnel
c'est cette ligne fine qui sépare ce que
j'aime ce que j'aime pas ce qui me fait
du bien de ce qui me met mal à l'aise ce
que je peux accepter de ce que je dois
refuser et donc dans l'auto défense
féministe il s'agit tout d'abord à
apprendre et identifiés ou cette limite
se trouve chez moi chez les autres
sa voix quand cette limite n'est pas
respectée et puis sur cette base là on
développe des stratégies pour faire
respecter cette limite un siège d'auto
défense et l'espace on peut donc
découvrir tester en sécurité des outils
verbaux non 20 beau physique
d'autodéfense et c'est aussi un espace
on peut échanger des expériences donc
être je vais me rendre contient je suis
pas la seule à qui ça arrive si je suis
pas la seule à qui ça arrive peut-être
et c'est pas de ma faute
quand ça m'arrive c'est un espace on
peut trouver une écoute un soutien une
solidarité dans le groupe
maintenant vous allez peut-être vous
dire bon il règne nous raconte des
carabistouilles parce que la proue envie
de nous convaincre convient de tout
temps c'est sage et vous avez envie de
vous méfier jamais trop quoi des gens
mais je peux prouver ce que j'ai dire
depuis une trentaine d'années il ya des
études scientifiques jeu l'autodéfense
féministes qui démontre que des femmes
qui ont suivi des formations comparées à
celles qui n'ont pas suivi de formation
et rapporte plein de conséquence positif
dans ses impacts positifs on trouve par
exemple meilleure confiance en soi une
meilleure image de soi une meilleure
image que notre corps plus d'autos
efficacité ça veut dire d'être
conviction que je suis capable que je
peux avoir un impact sur le monde moi de
colère et surtout surtout moins de peur
beaucoup moins de peur et on soit je
trouve que ce serait déjà largement
suffisant pour promouvoir l'auto défense
féministe partout mais il ya mieux
encore les mêmes études démontrent aussi
que les femmes qui ont subi des sages
pour de défense elles savent mieux s'en
sortir ça va mieux se défendre quand ils
sont confrontés une agression et après
ils ont mois des conséquences
psychologiques négatif et ce qui est
encore mieux c'est qu'elles sont moins
souvent confrontés à des agressions
après une formation que les autres
femmes donc ça avait été que
l'autodéfense féministe a un réel impact
préventif
nous avons déposé nos statuts en octobre
2000 et notre premier programme était
très modeste en juste quelques stages de
week end en autodéfense défense ferait
appel
et avec le temps il ya d'autres
associations qui nous ont demandé de
venir faire des animations pour le
public est comme ça ça agrandit peu à
peu pensant qu on à fonctionner en
autonomie ça veut dire sans financement
extérieur mais ça se traduit par
beaucoup le travail bénévole à côté d'un
travail qui paie les factures
[Musique]
et puis en 2005
on ne pouvait plus c'était vraiment rose
était de semaine et 60 80 heures de
travaux combiné et donc j'ai fait le
saut dans l'eau froide j'ai quitté mon
emploi pour pouvoir m'occuper à temps
plein de gars ans et ça nous a permis de
mieux faire connaître de trouver des
financements et développer de nouveaux
projets et donc depuis 2005 qu'on a pu
créer dix emplois
j'ai plus femmes et 35 formatrice en
belgique en france et en suisse
et aujourd'hui chaque année on touche
directement avec des animations 1700
personnes par an en plus de
l'autodéfense féministe on a développé
une approche d'éducation pas les pères
père a dit c'est une approche où nous
formons des femmes à encadrer des
groupes de réflexion sur la sécurité
avec d'autres femmes et donc les femmes
se posent la question tient quand est-ce
que je me sens en sécurité quand est-ce
que je me sens pas en sécurité pourquoi
est ce que je pourrais faire pour être
plus à l'aise et ses groupes existent
aujourd'hui pour des femmes à près de 55
ans pour des femmes issues de
l'immigration et pour les femmes qui
vivent avec un handicap intellectuel et
voit que c'est une femme comme elle qui
mène le groupe qui est la chef qui a des
solutions à apporter c'est quelque chose
qui donne beaucoup de courage aux femmes
on a aussi un projet qui s'appelle
enfants capables avec lequel on va dans
les écoles primaires ou en parallèle
le travail avec le personnel scolaire
les parents et les enfants de 6 à 12 ans
pour la prévention des violences ont
bien des enfants et dans toutes ces
animations les femmes et les filles nous
parle de cette peur qu'elles ont de
l'espace public et qui fait qu'elles
n'osent pas sortir qu'ils n'osent pas
sortir seul que elles n'osent pas sortir
à certains
à certains endroits à billets comme
éleveur pour faire ce qu'elles veulent
et donc des puits 2012 nous travaillons
sur l'aménagement de l'espace public
pour le rendre plus rassurant
accueillant et accessible pour toutes
les femmes et pour les filles ont fait
ça allait démarche exploratoire c'est un
outil d'analysé de genre de l'espace
public ou avec un petit groupe de femmes
en bas dans un quartier et connaissent
bien et par des questions et des
exercices ont fait sortir leur
expérience leur ressenti leur idée là
besoin par rapport à cet espace et on
communique après les résultats aux
responsables politiques et techniques
pour que les spas change
la plupart du temps on arrive quand
l'espace est déjà fait et donc après
coup on dit ce qui va pas dans l'espace
et ça veut dire que changer encore
quelque chose peut être compliqué ce
peut être cher ça les gens n'aiment pas
trop et c'est pourquoi namur est
vraiment un bon exemple parce que un ami
en a fait dans le l'autre sens on s'est
rendu compte qu'ils avaient quatre
projets de réaménagement de l'espace
public dans le centre ville et on a
proposé à la ville de namur de analyser
ces quartiers-là en amont avec les
femmes pour que dans les travaux on
puisse tenir compte de ce que les femmes
veulent et donc pendant deux ans on a
fait une dizaine de matchs avec les
namuroises on était en hiver le jour la
nuit pour vraiment couvrir toutes les
éventualités
on était surtout autour de la gare à
boumhel et dans le quartier caserne
avec les résultats on a fait un cahier
de recommandations assez détaillé rue
pas vu qu est-ce qui va qu'est ce qui va
pas on a présenté sa la commune et en
septembre 2010 est le collège communal à
adopter notre cahier de charges et l'a
intégrée dans le cahier de charges du
concours pour le quartier caserne
ça veut dire que les architectes et les
urbanistes qui voulait répondre à ce
concours que vous voulez participer par
participer il devait tignes compte de ce
que les femmes avaient dit dans les
marches et le projet gagnant coeur de
ville il tient assez content de ce que
les femmes avaient dit par rapport à
l'éclairage comment organiser les
trajets les chemins
comment rendre l'espace plus transparent
pour qu'on puisse anticiper ce qui se
passe plus loin la mixité des fonctions
et tout cela ils nous ont vraiment très
curieuse de voir à quoi ça va ressembler
en réalité parce que c'est une première
en belgique qui a tout un quartier qui
va être construit avec l'objectif de
diminuer la peur de femmes de ma propre
peur je le sens plus souvent je pourrais
vous raconter que oui j'ai vécu des
petites aventures
j'ai passé quatre mois en saccades
autres seuls en amérique centrale
je passe régulièrement des étés entier
seul dans une cabane dans le bas fond
des alpes où il ya personne ce genre de
choses mais pour moi c'est pas ça qui
est important
ce qui m'importe le plus c'est que au
quotidien il ya plein de choses plein de
questions qu'il ne me tracasse plus est
ce que c'est une bonne idée de parler
at-elle personnes que je connais pas est
ce que je dis quelque chose ou pas quand
quelque chose ne ronge
comment est ce que je vais m'organiser
pour rentrer après la fête pour ne pas
être seul qu'est ce que les gens vont
penser de moi tout ça ça n'a plus
d'importance pour moi c'est une charge
mentale qui a été
enlevez de mes épaules et je sens la
différence
et cette révolution là se saouler
soulagement cette liberté ça c'est
quelque chose que j'ai envie de
continuer à partager
[Musique]